no lemon hey everyone i'm abby sharpe
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be reviewing
20 year old lifestyle youtuber and
college student
sydney serena but first let me tell you
about my sponsor billbar
if you are new here hello but if you are
a regular
viewer you know that i am a big fan of
these bars
they literally taste like a chocolate
bar and they're just such an
easy convenient source of protein for
those really busy days
and hello parenthood i got a lot of
those so
i have eaten a lot of protein bars in my
day
and to find one that doesn't taste like
chalk honestly feels like a bit of a
miracle so i was
really excited about these bars today
let's take a look what flavor we're
going to get into i think we're taking
it back to
my favorite cookies and cream
so this one's got 17 grams of protein
reminds me of an oreo how could that be
bad now these are a lower sugar bar
for those of you looking for something
like that but if i were to have this
as like a post-workout snack i would
usually pair it with some fruit
or my oatmeal or toast it is also
so delicious chopped up and put into
oatmeal
try it but if you guys want to give
these bars a try check out the link in
the description
and use my promo code for 15 off of your
order
all right and as always you can pause
the screen or look at the description
for my general disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with disordered eating behaviors
as i will be discussing macros and
calories so
feel free to skip this if it's not
supportive to your journey
also don't forget to subscribe to my
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on an episode
all right folks let's see what sydney
has to
eat so the first thing i do every
morning is drink a glass of water
[Music]
what where's the lemon i hope she knows
that
without a slice of lemon her body is
just gonna like
shut down like nothing she eats is gonna
get absorbed
and she's probably gonna gain like 15
pounds from all the toxic sludge
that is going to sit undigested in her
gut
can i interest you in a sarcastic
comment
now i'm with you lemon honestly just
makes it taste better
maybe adds a little bit of vitamin c in
there but i think she's going to be okay
let's see what she's having for
breakfast i used to like to have big
breakfasts
but now for some reason i get sick in
the morning so
recently i've just been having a little
thing of yogurt
i also don't like having a heavy
breakfast because if i work
out afterwards i just feel really sick
okay so it's not uncommon to find that a
big breakfast doesn't sit well before
you know a really hard workout
especially if you work out first thing
in the morning
like it seems like sydney does
ultimately you really gotta listen to
your body
and it honestly sounds like she's doing
just that but from a sports nutrition
perspective
it is ideal to focus on a mixture of
carbs
and protein in about a three to one
ratio before
a workout and also to try to keep that
meal
lower in fiber and lower in fat which
can cause some digestive distress for
some people
so yogurt and berries is actually a
pretty good choice here so we've got
you know a little bit of carbs in the
yogurt and the berries as well and a
little bit of protein in that yogurt as
well
other light options to help supply just
that little bit of energy boost before
an activity
could be a few slices of toast with some
ricotta and honey
or a simple fruit based smoothie with
some yogurt or
milk
[Music]
okay so this looks like a great workout
that really doesn't require
any added equipment or any added
expenses
i think if covet has given me anything
good it's
really an awesome repertoire of free
online workouts
yes i'm definitely looking forward to
doing like an occasional barry's boot
camp one day
someday but i also really enjoyed the
flexibility of working out
at home on my own time and these
workouts look
super great but i'm just going to be
honest i saw some cake in my fridge and
i was
this close to eating it but i'm trying
to be healthy
so instead i'm gonna make a smoothie
so i think this is a really innocent
comment and one that most of us
don't even bat an eye out because you
know die culture messages like this are
just
so deeply woven into the fabric of our
everyday lives but i just want to draw
attention to this so that
hopefully over time you can start to
hear these messages
and either kind of refute them or just
tune them out
the audience clap track following an
announcement that she was having a
healthy smoothie while resisting her own
urges to have some cake
it does perpetuate this idea that we
should be praised
for choosing low-calorie diet foods
while exercising our willpower
to avoid those high sugar sweets now the
reason this behavior isn't something we
necessarily want to or really promote
is that when we purposefully avoid foods
we tend to end up wanting them even more
and you can only open the fridge and
look at beautiful cake
so many times before you say it
get at me and eat the whole thing but
instead when we allow ourselves access
to foods that we enjoy
every single day we're much more likely
to be able to stick to healthy habits
long term
because our life as a whole is a lot
more fulfilling
like i said i think this is a very
innocent comment and something that you
probably hear all the time in the sense
that you know
hey we're trying to be healthy so i'm
not going to eat the cake no harm
no foul but i'm just pointing it out
because i don't think it's so bad
to have a little bit of cake every once
in a while if that is what brings you
joy
all right let's see what's next
dude is butter a carb yes
so my smoothies are very specific
first step is banana next is frozen
strawberries
i'm gonna add spinach then i'm just
adding in my favorite protein powder
i love peanut butter
okay so this looks like a great
post-workout meal
we've got carbs in the english muffin
and fruit
protein in the protein powder and some
healthy fats in
the nut butter and we got a little
spinach in the smoothie which i know
sydney was worried about ruining her
go-to smoothie recipe
but it looks like she was pleasantly
surprised so that's great honestly i
think that if she was
really wanting that cake in the fridge
it would have been
totally fine to swap it in for the
english muffin
i mean i know the diet culture has
reduced cake down to
devil's food literally but if you strip
it of its moral weight
and really break it down it's really
just carbs and fat and an english muffin
with butter
is also carbs and fat so the cake
also represents a source of pleasure and
a sensual experience that
you just can't get out of a piece of
toast especially if it's going to
lead to an overall more satisfying and
sustainable diet
i say have the cake remember what i say
about naked carbs rather than thinking
about what we should remove
from a diet let's think about what we
can add in
and if we pair that cake with the
protein shake
suddenly we've actually got a relatively
balanced meal
and one that is a hell of a lot more
exciting than an english muffin
just saying but i do love me a good
english muffin so
yeah both work for me let's take a look
at lunch
it's lunch time so today's lunch i'm
gonna make
pasta
[Music]
i actually use this protein pasta that's
made out of chickpeas that's really good
and i don't eat a ton of meat so it's a
good supplement for that
and then as you guys saw i just put some
tomatoes in there some pasta sauce
bon appetit so this looks like a
simple and satisfying lunch sydney
mentioned she doesn't eat a lot of meat
so she
loves the chickpea pasta for a source of
satisfying protein
and my regular viewers know that i do
too
if we compare regular pasta to a brand
like bonza chickpea pasta we're actually
looking at about
10 grams fewer carbs two and a half
times the fiber
and twice the protein per two ounce
serving in
the chickpea pasta that is pretty
awesome to me
i would probably add in like a little
swirl of olive oil or maybe some
parmesan cheese in there for some
satisfying
fat and also ideally throw in some
frozen veggies just to beef this up
without
a huge to do but for a meal that
probably
took her 10 minutes from start to finish
it does sound
pretty damn good let's hit up dinner
surprise i'm hungry again i'm gonna make
dinner tonight's specialty is vegan
tacos
while the tofu is cooking i decided to
chop up some of those tomatoes that i
used earlier and then
i'm also putting in some more spinach
because i'm trying to be healthy
this is my second spinach of the day
[Music]
i forgot the guac
[Music]
okay so this looks awesome we've got
protein in the tofu
carbs and the tortillas and a little fat
in the guacamole
oil and cheese plus a little veg i would
say that most adults would probably need
to bulk this up a little bit more
so maybe serving this with like a side
salad or with some sauteed bell peppers
or corn and some other kind of
vegetables
but i will say that it's kind of nice to
see a youtuber
not eat a family size salad for one i
also appreciate that sydney isn't afraid
to cook with oil which
may be why this meal while physically
kind of small is probably relatively
saturating
for her let's see what she has to say
about her diet i hope you guys liked
watching i hope you guys got some new
recipe ideas and inspiration i think
eating healthy just makes me feel so
much better and you know that's the
amazing thing
about eating a balanced diet not only
does it help fuel our body physically
but it can also help improve our
emotional health as well
so just consider the evidence and the
research
on food as it relates to mental health
so
research suggests that following a
balanced mediterranean diet for example
can help to reduce symptoms of
depression and anxiety
from moderate levels to normal levels
in just three weeks but it may be a bit
of a two-way interaction
where healthy eating may impact mood
and mood may impact healthy eating
so it's definitely not without its
complexities but let's switch gears to
talk about the stats and of course a
trigger warning
that if this is triggering of course you
can skip ahead to the next section
here so sydney is consuming about 600
calories
with 20 protein 36 carbs
and 44 fat based on just my calculations
here
she's a little low in b vitamins folate
and vitamin e and also a little bit low
in
fiber as well now first of all let's
talk about what i
like here i get a lot of requests to
talk about healthy eating in college
because i know that this is a season of
life that
does present some unique challenges like
being on a tight budget
living on your own for the first time
eating out
or having limited cooking appliances
tools
and cooking skills what i will say is
that
i think sydney does a really great job
sharing some
inexpensive super simple and ultimately
really accessible meal ideas for young
college students who are cooking for one
i think all of her meals took no more
than 20 minutes to put together
were based on inexpensive plant-based
proteins like chickpeas
and tofu and also didn't require any
fancy tools specialty ingredients or
skills
i also appreciated that it seems like
sydney largely is eating what she likes
while making small but likely more
sustainable
healthy habits for herself so for
example she
loves her smoothie just as it is but she
tries to experiment by adding like a
little handful of spinach to
make a little bit more nutritious
honestly i think one of the biggest
mistakes that
a lot of people make when trying to take
on health promoting behaviors
is they attempt to take on too much too
fast and then they just give it all up
but i think once sydney gets down with
having that little bit of spinach in her
taco and those few tomatoes in her pasta
and a little bit of spinach in a
smoothie she may over time
be able to build on that to add more
variety
and greater portions while still
enjoying her meal
finally it was nice to see a youtuber
who isn't explicitly
demonizing stereotypically bad or
junk foods so she has white bread she
puts cheese on her taco
and she cooks with a good glug of oil
and she isn't trying to sell us on any
particular way of eating
or adhering to some kind of diet label
she says in the video that she eats
mainly plant-based
but she leaves room for flexibility with
certain foods that she enjoys
like yogurt and cheese and i think for a
lot of people
that's just what works best but now
let's chat over a few little gentle
nutrition tips that college students
like sydney could consider as she
expands her
culinary chops first of all i ran some
very rough calculations
and i'd estimate that sydney's needs are
actually closer to around 1900 to 2000
calories
assuming she's doing some moderate
activity three to four days per week
i get the sense that sydney really is
eating intuitively as it doesn't appear
like she's
actively trying to shave calories
anywhere off of her day
but it's not uncommon for young college
students to under eat
just out of lack of time or distraction
or lack of enthusiasm for cooking or
lack of structure in their day
this is often why having a relatively
stable meal and snack schedule
can help us prioritize eating and allow
us to
mindfully check in with our hunger and
fullness a little bit more frequently
to help us better honor our body's cues
distraction is a
really good appetite suppressant so for
those of you who
tell me that you can't eat intuitively
because you'll actually under eat
or that you've never dieted before but
you still don't feel
hungry enough to eat enough consider if
you're just not
giving yourself enough time to actively
tune into your cues some of us may have
to make a little bit more effort to
check
in with our bodies rather than just
passively hope that we will get some
obnoxious siren going off
to tell us that it's time to eat and
having a little bit of a schedule
is a great way to help achieve that as
for nutrition specific recommendations
well i love that sydney isn't afraid of
added fat i wouldn't want this to come
at the expense of getting enough protein
carbs and fiber for her young active
body
so i would try to focus on adding maybe
one or two extra snacks into her day
something simple and balanced with the
hunger crushing combo
like a piece of pita with some hummus on
there
or some edamame some protein oatmeal
hard-boiled eggs and fruit or some
popcorn with lots of nutritional yeast
and speaking of nutritional yeast that
will also help with the low b12
in addition to focusing a little bit
more on foods like
eggs yogurt milk or soy milk
beans frozen spinach potatoes and whole
grains
all of which are relatively low cost
finally
once she becomes a little bit more
enthusiastic about the spinach and
tomatoes in her meals
she might want to consider adding a
little bit more produce into rotation
just to help her meet those fiber needs
so for cost-effective
options maybe some cabbage broccoli or
carrots to start finally just a quick
little note on sydney's relationship
with food
in short cities generation has a
mountainous battle ahead when it comes
to escaping diet culture
and misinformation about food and
nutrition her comment
or i guess i should say her choice in
comedic editing
about choosing the smoothie over the
cake reinforces this belief
that we should be admired for the act of
restraint
or restriction and i'm not going to
fault her on this i mean
she's 20 years old this is the dominant
discourse
that she lives in but i'm just pointing
out to encourage those of you watching
to be a little bit more critical of
comments like this
let's work together to shift this
conversation
so that this is not the default
perspective
otherwise i would say that sydney seems
to have a
super normal healthy relationship with
food for a young
20 year old she seems to just eat what
she likes
she has a good general understanding of
nutrition
but not in an obsessive way and for the
most part
she doesn't seem to cut out or demonize
foods
or whole food groups so in conclusion
i may be like 13 years older than this
girl which is
cringy for me to say out loud but i
genuinely enjoyed her channel
sydney seems pretty down to earth
relatable
and sweet in a really youthful
non-threatening kind of way
and her content while not really geared
towards people like me
is definitely light and fun and on that
note that is
all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with your thoughts on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye